et bien pour 62 % des femmes le niveau
de culture générale est la priorité
numéro un
rechercher chez un homme ensuite c'est
la performance sexuelle
puis vient la richesse pour 9 % des
femmes puis la beauté pour 8%
un papa récemment castaldi bout chez les
hommes sachez le ce et 38% sont là à
rechercher une femme cultivée 42% sont
d'abord à rechercher une femme qui fait
très bien l'amour est ensuite viennent
la beauté 12% et la richesse eu pour
cent c'est quoi vous alors présents
parfois c'est l'humour le mot d'humour
les mains les mains très important mais
oui mais il n'y a pas là alors là
seulement à la non non non je dirais
cultiver ses l'abstrait bien d'amour est
très belle donc cultiver le mythe
vous allez vous dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai j'ai dormi dans des changes
et par là les noms devraient vraiment
coincé ça leur met d'accord mais dire et
je leur ai jamais mon âme mais je vais
me connais une fable était assez joli
mais tellement teubé que c'était un prêt
mais c'est vrai elle était animatrice
non c'est un break parce qu'une fois
qu'on a fait l'amour qu'est ce que ça
vous ferait on est assez important d'une
section à vous moi c'était la
gentillesse la bienveillance zappala l'a
pas dénoncé entrevoit la voix l'album
c'est cultiver ont un chez les femmes
elles disent après elle cherche donc
faire performances sexuelles richesse et
beauté alors moi je mettrais l'amour un
amour un ben moi parce que c'est 99 %
d'heures que le sexe est toujours
intéressé par mois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc le 501 ouais euh
la culture en deux et la beauté en 3j
l'argent k way je m'en fous j'aimerais
c'est vrai qu'il prend bâtir il s'agira
du mal et les faire très bien l'amour ça
veut rien dire
ouais maintenant parce qu'en fait c'est
bien à cake non mais c'est vrai ou faux
le raté de quoi ça se décrète pas c'est
l'alchimie d'une sorte de magie et ça
peut être très très bien de faire
l'amour tous les deux qu'on peut être
complètement ratée avec gigean ni
d'intention ans avait pris bon exemple
c'est complètement absurde mais ça ne
veut rien dire moi je choisirais en
premier l'une urs hany moi la culture en
fait non parce que je trouve que c'est
pas important donc ça veut dire l'humour
donc ça veut dire que en fait celui qui
vous plairait plus ici c'est jean michel
c'est le plus rôle non mais bon c'est
dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
machinegames bad langue de bois ici en
direct vous dire un truc de ses bouquets
sky est mon premier
ce que je préfère sont mes partenaires
c'est au départ le physique je crois la
route et du coeur mais aussi à la beauté
du corps la deuxième chose c'est
l'intelligence des discussions
enflammées sagem est également la
fidélité la fidélité je trouve ça avec
vous c'est mal barré
donc arrêtée mais elle est cultivée en
fait d'aller tout petit vlv voilà bah
moi c'est belle et sébastien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors en premier la culture ah ouais
ouais pas tout est cultivée très cultivé
et est vrai très très cultivé ah oui
c'est une intelligence redoutable
oui c'est après que ça se voit oui c'est
vrai vous allez être surpris
non mais non parce que c'est une belle
je sais je la connais pas je la connais
pas super bien et j'ai vu que
quelquefois très intelligente elle nous
est dans les monts chéri à quoi tu t'en
les astuces mélanie l'intelligence n'a
rien à voir avec la culture et oui la
wilaya pas d'intelligence
deuxièmement la beauté mais exactement
elle est très belle non monsieur je sais
je les fais et troisièmement fait savoir
sa ministre s'est également fait la
viande amour pidgeon de 2 l'an non mais
vous savez vous déjà au début parce
qu'on est balance ou les deux châteaux
adversaire et vous me dites souvent que
pas tous les mois on se ressemble
beaucoup au club un peu peur tous cas
non mais c'est vrai vous dit souvent
qu'on souhaite comparer vous allez même
car j'ai l'impression de vous avoir la
maison
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas bon alors c'est
qu'ils sont encore vivants oui alors moi
aussi je balance alors premier point
d'amener un cdd caen qui joue après 7
quel des condamnés des chromes à deux
premiers on sait quel siècle comme vous
mais ça s'est passé ni même des quand
vous aurez base pour des cons comme ça
tous les deux mais et à partir de 30 ans
l'ascendant est important c'est à dire
si je continue je bête moi d'abord qui
me fasse rire parce qu'une tournée 100
plaintes grand écart c'est pas grave et
une journée sans alain green 1 alors il
est drôle pas là il est très très bas
depuis le 4 août bien dans son lit
huawei bien sûr il est très très drôle
là bas ça qui est drôle
après que je les admire sur le plan
intellectuel parce que ça compense sa
nullité en bricolage faut bien quand
même qui est un avantage
et troisièmement qu'il a sur olic parce
que j'ai la chance d'avoir un mari qui
est très bien enfoncé xv ont très bien
en venir
action est ce que vous recherchez vous
c'est votre jeu court et puis apple
langue de bois et tout un tas et du sexe
de taille du portefeuille bataille de la
voiture il faut pas qu'ils aient un sexe
trop gros à une boîte auto pied sinon ça
rentre pas vu arriver un range rover
j'ai tout de suite su que nous deux ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
grosse bagnole ils sont tous battus et
les dix parts de vous me dire à quelle
heure vous arrivez vous le 9
agathe vous c'est quoi qui compte et
mont-joli soit marrant il faudra soit
très gentille et brew qui sont massifs
où qu'ils soient gentils et faut qu'ils
soient et où qu'ils soient et protecteur
ah ouais en fait ouais c'est pas du tout
je sens pair à pair c'est pas souvent
non mais c'est vrai ma très bien oui
mais il n'y a pas tous à jean-michel
l'instinct maternel
c'est n'importe quoi donc avec le site
des sages que je suis pour l'alcool
naturel des simples et non mais l'alluré
générale je boite à voter non mais il
est resté dans les clichés pour ça je
restais là dedans la beauté évidemment
ce que c'est qu'en fait la gueule dans
le couple faut qu'on me tire et le
physique reste comme ça on se dit elle
est chiante et comcast défaite des
français la culture et la culture
gros bovins s'il aime le cinéma
cinéphiles cinéma peut aimer le cinéma
ne pas y aller les films chez soi mais
qui aime la coupe aimer l'amour et ne
pas le faire à ce mois et par quoi on
parle d'un chroniqueur il s'en passe et
merci
[Applaudissements]
alors moi ce serait déjà très
intelligente à la place de très cultivé
et bien ce serait fidèle avant de déjà
bien faire l'amour plus important un
site très beau oui pourquoi pas avec
plaisir également chanté malheureusement
le seul qui est sur le dos de cali c'est
jean-michel franchement je ne vois pas
je suis très fidèle
ah oui à l'amour n'a pas de vision
d'apple
ça va aller